في مشهد غريب تداول رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو اثار تساؤلات كثيره
لجرافه فوق سطح مبنى مكون من 11 طابقا في
مصر حيث تساءل البعض عن كيفيه وصول
الجرافه الى هناك وبين تعليقات ساخره من
هنا وهناك الا ان الحقيقه انه يتم نقلها
برافعه ثقيله جدا يمكنها ان ترفع مئات
الاطنان لمستويات عاليه
[موسيقى]
اشعلت سجده النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو مهاجم النصر السعودي مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي عقب احتفاله بهدف الفوز
في مرمى فريق الشباب تفاعل الكثيرون مع
الفيديو المتداول البعض اعتبر انه تاثر
بزملائه خلال فتره اقامته بالسعوديه بينما
اكتفى اخرون بابداء استغرابهم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حشرات طالبه مصريه مقطع فيديو مؤثرا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لتوصيل والدها
لها على دراجته الهوائيه وذلك لحضور
اختباراتها في الكليه في الساعه السادسه
صباحا الفيديو لقياس استحسانا كبيرا
واعجاب الملايين
[موسيقى]
في مشهد جميل قرد في حديقه الحيوانات يطلب
طلبا غريبا وهو رؤيه طفل رضيع يبلغ من
العمر 3 سنوات في ولايه كنتاكي الامريكيه
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات